what does squirrel taste like squirrel
tastes like squirrel for one year I only
ate foods that I grew and foraged one
year without grocery stores or
restaurants nothing packaged or
processed nothing shipped long distances
literally everything that I entire year
came from my garden or that I harvested
from nature my name is Rob Greenfield
I'm an environmental activist who
embarks on extreme adventures to bring
attention to important environmental and
social issues basically I believe that
our current global industrial food
system is broken everywhere you look
it's causing severe destruction to
people to other species and to the earth
as a whole and so I wanted to do
something extreme I've always had the
question would it be possible to step
away from big AG step away from the
global industrial food system and could
I exist without grocery stores and
restaurants and actually grow all my own
food I couldn't find people that had
done it so for me the solution was to do
it myself and see if it was possible
when I started I didn't know how much
Sun does a carrot need how much water to
put on your collards or your Swiss chard
I was just literally on the internet
researching every plant and how to do it
food didn't get bland because I ate over
300 species of food I grew over a
hundred different foods and I forged
over 200 different foods so that's
almost a new species for every day of
the entire year I made my own flour by
dehydrating cassava and yam then I could
make my own tortillas and bread I
fermented a lot of foods and may
things like sauerkraut and honey wine
ginger beer
I ate dozens and dozens of different
meals throughout the year that were
really varied so it really didn't get
boring I chose Florida because as
someone who had minimal experience I did
want to be somewhere where I could grow
food year-round it can be done in colder
climates but I wanted to choose an
easier place since I was just a beginner
and what I chose to do was not live on a
farm not live out in the countryside
because I wanted to impact people I
wanted people to see me growing my food
I wanted to interact with the community
when I arrived in Florida one of the
first things that I did is I connected
with the local food growing movement I
went to the community garden so I just
really immersed in the community and got
to know people and I asked people in the
community if they would like to have
free food growing right in their yard
rather than just grass and the people
lined up to have me turn their yard into
a garden and so I ended up having six
front yard Gardens and they were
available for anyone to eat from quickly
it went from grass to having really
enough food for dozens or even hundreds
of people to eat from and they were
basically community gardens anybody
could walk in and eat the food for the
year I lived in a tiny house that I
built out of 99% secondhand materials
it's 10 feet by 10 feet so very small
you know my arm span is 6 feet so I've
span across most of it basically it was
a bed a desk with a chair a freezer to
store food a couple of shelves to store
a lot of food and then under the bed
there was storage as well being in
Florida I was able to utilize outside as
well so my kitchen was an outdoor
kitchen and that was powered by
rainwater so my sink was just rain water
for washing dishes and hands and I also
had an outdoor compost toilet where I
would compost my poop and pee and turn
that into fertile soil rather than
wasting water and shipping it off to be
someone else's problem that fertilizer
is used on fruit trees so not on your
kale and stuff on the ground but on
fruit trees where the fruit is
high above and then lastly I had an
outdoor shower as well and the water
from that was harvested from rain and
then the water would be used to water
banana plants to grow bananas I gave
myself six months to prepare but that
ended up being ten months before I
actually started and I started from
scratch I had to get seeds and soil and
figure out the absolute basics my basic
strategy was to plant way more than I
would need so that way I would have
enough so that meant more work but it
ensured the success I talked to the
local gardeners and farmers and I asked
what grows so ridiculously well that
even if you barely know what you're
doing it's not just going to survive but
it's actually going to thrive I asked
what has the fewest pests what produces
a huge amount of food and what can
handle neglect and that is what I
planted and most of these were foods
that I had never eaten before you don't
see at the grocery store and a lot of
them I didn't even know the name of
things like Shia or Moringa Orca took
there were dozens of plants that became
my staple foods that are staples for
people around the world but that were
pretty much unknown to me and most of
the people I was around a year is a
pretty long time I mean imagine taking
any sort of diet and doing it for an
entire year through the year I had my
ups and downs at times felt my absolute
best and then there was times that I was
worried about my health one of the most
interesting times was just at the very
beginning it was just about a week and a
half in and I realized that my digestion
was the best that I had felt in my adult
life by the middle of the year I found
that I had a deficiency I thought in fat
and protein that's one of the hardest
things to really get for me this is
really funny because I was plant-based
fully for two years and I didn't eat any
meat I was trying to grow plant-based
protein I was growing beans and
geez that did really well but I was
trying to grow peanuts and sunflowers
and I was really excited to make my own
peanut butter literally from soil to the
jar of peanut butter I was so excited
for it but the problem was the squirrels
wanted my peanuts and they wanted my
sunflowers and I grew I put a lot of
energy into it and I almost
I barely ate just a few because they
would eat them long before they were
even ready for me to eat them so in
permaculture there's a saying and that's
turned your problem into your solution
the squirrels were my problem they were
eating my plant-based form of protein so
I hate the squirrels in doing so I got
protein that I needed and I took care of
something that was causing me a hard
time in my garden I definitely had some
controversy over that in the
neighborhood but for me it's not about
black and white we look at our food on
our plates and because it's a grocery
store or because it's a restaurant we
just trust it we don't think about where
it came from the impact that it had on
other people other species and on the
land you can look at what I'm doing is
you see it direct
you see I ate a squirrel but if you are
getting food from a farm even if it's
vegan food there's a good chance they're
killing squirrels or rats or or mice
that are that are eating the food so for
me I'm in the direct fire you see these
things that I'm doing but the reality is
is that we're all doing this we just
don't see it and so it makes it a very
different thing when you immerse in your
food you start to understand the reality
of the dinners that we're eating and
then also I was in Wisconsin at that
time on a trip for the summer I went
fishing and a caught fish and
particularly lake trout which are one of
the fattier fishes that are out there
and I actually ate literally the entire
trout even the head the eyes the brain
because that's where so much of the fat
is also deer that were hit by cars so
some people would call that roadkill
I call them deer that were killed by
cars so that was basically between the
fish and the deer that was what brought
me back into balance and and gave my
body the nourishment that I wasn't
getting otherwise by the end of the
project I did a body fat composition
I had 15% body fat so I was able to work
my way back up and at the end of the
year I felt honestly better than I had
recalled in my adult life I was
healthier and I was happier and I didn't
get sick once throughout the entire year
and the ironic thing is I have a little
bit of a cold right now
after this and getting back into the
food system my experience was that this
created some of the happiest and
healthiest days of my life so far so my
goal wasn't just to grow in forage all
of my own food my goal was to help other
people do so as well
so during the year I started Gardens for
single moms and we built gardens for
five single-parent families in the
neighborhoods and helped them grow their
own food and we planted over 200 fruit
trees that were publicly accessible for
everyone to eat from and then free seed
project and we sent out 5,000 garden
starter kits to people to grow their own
healthy food across the country a tomato
is good on a plate when you get it at
the restaurant of the grocery store but
just to plant that from seed to watch it
grow to see it be this little green ball
that you can eat and then bigger and
then this right juicy plump tomato and
then to pick that and to have you know
picked off the insects to the point
where you can actually get to eat it
because the insects didn't and you went
through all of those times together with
that tomato and then you get to eat that
tomato it might not actually taste
better but it tastes better there's just
that love that went into it and you feel
it and you're like this is the best
tomato I've ever had most of the food
that we buy at the grocery store today
is shipped long distances often from
halfway around the world if not halfway
across the country it's packaged in
plastic that will be around for hundreds
of years either in the landfill or
in our oceans and our lakes and our
forests its processed and filled with
ingredients that aren't really good for
us ingredients that we can't name that
aren't real food and it uses a ton of
pesticide
and herbicides and fertilizers that
runoff and pollute our water so this
food although it appears harmless on our
plates has so many repercussions to
people to other species and to the world
that we depend on for our existence and
that's why I think it's important to
know that and if that doesn't match your
value system to find food that doesn't
cause that destruction to the world that
we live on
[Music]